the brutal effects of russia's invasion
of ukraine are devastating the global
economy the world bank is slashing its
global growth forecast for 2022 by
nearly a full percentage point
world bank chief economist carmen
reinhart warned that the downgraded
projection of 3.2 growth could end up
being too optimistic amid quote
exceptional uncertainty for the global
economy
global finance financial leader leaders
are in washington this week for joint
meetings of the international monetary
fund and world bank
food insecurity skyrocketing inflation
and the rising risk of debt crises in
poorer countries will top the agenda
now russia's war in ukraine is the main
reason for the worsening economic
outlook from the world bank it expects
ukraine's economy to contract a stunning
45 percent this year russia russia's own
economy is expected to shrink 11
according to world bank forecasts
russia's annual inflation is rising at
its quickest pace in decades since the
invasion of ukraine
the onslaught of western sanctions and
the withdrawal of multinationals is
hurting the economy but that doesn't
appear to worry russian president
vladimir putin
we can now confidently say that the
policy of sanctions towards russia has
failed the economic blitzkrieg strategy
didn't work moreover the initiators
themselves couldn't get away with the
sanctions i'm talking about inflation
and unemployment growth and economic
dynamics worsening in the u.s and
european countries
putin
acknowledges sharp jump in consumer
prices saying his government would raise
pensions and the salaries of state
employees to ease the impact on russians
meanwhile russian central bank governor
elvira nabiolina has warned the economy
could not survive indefinitely on its
financial reserves and would have to
change to deal with the impact of
international sanctions
which have frozen almost half of the 640
billion dollars that russia had in its
gold and forex reserves
economists believe the worst impact is
still to come and say russia is likely
to plunge into a deep recession
the world bank expects the economy to
contract by more than 11 this year
in moscow mayor sergi sobianen warned
that around 200 000 people risk losing
their jobs in the capital alone because
foreign enterprises have suspended
operations or decided to leave the
russian market
even if the war ends soon many
multinational companies are unlikely to
return in the short term fearing more
disruptions